how well does Faith remember his iconic
chip in a traveler who was the announcer
on TV I was Faldo and Nance what club
were you using I was hitting a 60 degree
out of the bunker what number PGA Tour
win was it for you is that 10 I think it
was 10. how far away from the hole were
you probably 35 feet who are you facing
in the playoff and what did he gesture
to you when the ball went in I was
facing bug Daniel Berger and he gave me
non-emphatic thumbs up but it was a nice
gesture anyways I knew that he didn't
mean it what color shirt and belt were
you wearing probably wearing a navy
shirt gray belt with gray pants what was
the call on TV oh just as he did it at
the John Deere just as he did at the
John Deere what was your celebration
after that's that's the easy one I
turned and I threw my wedge kind of from
the middle of the shaft because I'd spun
the wedge and I threw it at the corner
of the bunker Michael threw the rake in
unison and we just ran and jumped up
like I just caught a touchdown path